I think some
so I got you a hotel room I had the key
in my pocket still yeah I know you
refused to go up in the room no I
couldn't get up it was so hot [__]
you were sitting in the sun on the
sidewalk I know yeah yeah
I think you're nuts
the trademarked here apparently
how's your day going more pretty good
pretty good
anything changed in your life what do
you mean I don't know I I just edited
your videos I'm looking I'm thinking
about you the whole time I'm doing this
going you have so much potential I know
and I I hate being this guy who's
harping on you saying oh you should do
this or you should just do that or you
just stop the drugs and all that [__]
and I hate I hate being that person but
Tom [__] drugs Mark I just and he's
got a job you know what I mean well even
you know I keep keep using the drugs in
fact double double the drug intake and
start a [__] YouTube channel yeah
people will watch you'll make money yeah
you will I hope you do it thanks um
but you have to hang onto a phone for
longer than 24 hours in 24 hours yeah
it's gonna be hard I got a feeling
people will watch you though
I was like a drop in fashion maybe a
screen test I don't know
I think I could I think I could work out
for something
yeah well I mean I mean social media
seems to be the
the thing for so many different careers
so many different people yeah and if you
became a
a thing on social media you'd probably
open up doors for all these other things
you want to do it's not about social
media I don't know yeah I guess I know
actually if I have a career I guess I
don't know
I still think you're amazing
even after
the other day when you were just sitting
on the curb smearing ice cream all over
your body I have all of my body um sorry
I was just performance art I suppose
yeah I realize that as as you're doing
it lactation as a manifest destiny no
but you're just being a whatever you
want to call it
what do you mean no well I mean I would
call it being a dick but there's other
terms for it probably more flattering
um and that's part of just who you want
to be right now at this point in your
life
and I bet you one day that'll change and
you'll be an amazing human being yeah
I think all that craziness is what makes
you fascinating
I suppose
am I crazy like soundtrack I guess I
know
[Music]
Mr TV
so you don't you want to use the room I
have the key still I'll give you the key
um yeah I guess yeah are you serious
about wanting to stay there full time oh
my gosh I mean it's nice to have
somewhere to be yeah I mean I think it
would be stabilizing for you I suppose
yeah
that would be great um I need a
following two and stuff you know I'll
get you a real phone yeah a phone that
works I don't work I'm sure they all
work but yeah I know so for some reason
you said that one didn't work
we'll get you a real phone get your room
when's the last time you brush your
teeth
I don't really brush my teeth I mean I
only needs like a shower a boss honestly
you needed one the other day it's
awesome Angels you know I mean it's like
a nice luxury bath you know I mean [__]
I need to find a doctor you know what I
mean uh
I need to go to clinic and start my sex
change honestly
I've already delayed it long enough it's
time to just start doing it ah
you understand why I have a hard time
with that with what with you wanting a
sex change when you when you can even
you can't even go up to you can't walk
up the stairs to a hotel room you can't
even keep a phone for 24 hours you can't
do anything yeah I know exactly which is
why I'm writing so you want to do it's
like something that's going to change
your life forever does it take life
forever exactly and I I just don't buy
that this is the right mindset to make a
decision like that
I definitely know that it's what I want
you know what I mean look I understand
that's what you want right now but you
also wanted to smear ice cream all over
your body and face the other day you
also wanted to
spit all over somebody who's helping you
out you wanted this video no you come in
here you're spitting all over the floor
and stuff like that do I yeah I don't
mean we just watch your videos huh
you're obnoxious you should watch your
videos I'm buying Rock shows yeah
yeah yes you're absolutely obnoxious how
do you mean I'll show you when we're
done here
I don't mean to be rude I don't know I
guess I'm just kind of a little
outspoken maybe yes you're you're more
than outspoken you're you're obnoxious
what do you mean
demanding that I get you a house
demanding that I I don't mean to be rude
it's just kind of like you know what I
mean
it's just kind of you know what I mean
no I don't know what you mean
I don't know you're one of the only
people out there that like helps me out
you know I mean I don't mean to be rude
about it you know yeah I I don't want
anything from you I just I just hate
seeing you be so
insanely self-destructive
that's very true and and disrespectful
cutting off some part of your body could
be terribly
it could be something you regret
terribly one day I definitely would
never will
I definitely never will
I think my biggest aspiration is to be a
woman is just you know being immigrant
it's really hard to find the right
healthcare services and stuff why do you
need to be a woman why can't you just
appreciate women like I do I do
appreciate them yeah I mean so do I
they're like my favorite I'm not you
know I mean it's not
why do you have to be one that's all I
want to be is a woman no why don't you
style them why don't you beautify them
why don't you just treat them well like
I do that equally as well exactly you
could do that you can do that instead
no but overall I'd love to be a woman
you know what I mean why do you want to
be a woman because it's all I want to
read through it I do not like being a
man you know what I mean it's like an
alien my own body you know yeah I can't
I can't relate to that any of that
I just I think there's a part of me you
know what I mean it just doesn't
understand my anatomy you know what I
mean like it's uh
like maybe the biggest facet of Maya but
here there are many fashion designers
who love women they don't need to like
cut off their genitalia and try to be
one they can just like dress them
beautifully or style them beautifully or
or whatever they do yeah but it's like
I'm just there to concentrate myself for
the sake of um him playing something I
mean I truly do want to be a woman you
know what I mean
see here's what kills me you're like the
most handsome man I've ever seen I'm
disgusting and I really do not like
being a man
I think I make a very ugly boy you know
before Marc Jacob started his uh his
line he had a line called stinky rot
pretty much that's what this is the
before I would say in life you know what
I mean
because if not how I want to make my
name in
um
in the future that's a great way of
remembering that there was a past in
which um
I was um
making mistakes I asked them
yeah but you're making a lot of mistakes
right now you're young and impulsive and
a little bit crazed and maybe there's a
bipolar or polar borderline or something
like that's going on too
because your personality changes daily
how do you mean sometimes hourly
there's a side to me I suppose sometimes
I'm a little um
I don't say aggressive but I like I'm
very adamant to be a certain way yep I
know yeah I've seen it yeah I've seen
all your personalities I think
I know that's true business baby no I
still think you're great
thank you for that I like all of your
personalities
but this this one right here where
you're a little bit
sober I'm not sober you're also yeah
yeah I like this personality this is my
favorite
sobering or sober minded or more like no
you're just like we can have intelligent
conversation we could talk whatever you
want to talk about and you could you
could follow through or instead of just
like spitting and screaming and
demanding oh yeah sorry one one why
because my feet when they got in pain
why are you feed into so much pain
you're stepping on glass or something
like that no it's just sometimes I lose
my shoes
here I'll give you
I take care of them I don't want to talk
about something
I can make your life easier
yeah but you have to follow through and
cooperate with that you can't just say
what I want to do leave the money on the
on the sidewalk that you did before with
me I never did that you did that you
think I didn't I did I you did I gave
you 40 bucks once and you you got up and
walked away and you left 40 bucks on the
curb I had to go give it to you
did you yeah this is years ago though oh
okay oh years ago
I must have just falling out I don't
know
you're just you're just a wild creature
No One's Gonna tame you wild creatures
remember that movie Denise Richards and
um it wasn't enough Campbell I don't
you've never seen that wild creatures
well things Wild Things I think I saw
that yeah yeah
what's your favorite movie we talked
about this the other day with one of my
favorite movies honestly is Melancholia
by Lars vondria
it's like it came out in uh
I think it's one of my favorite movies
honestly Kristen Dunst was on the plane
with me coming back from New York the
other day really what she she and her
husband
I think they had a baby too
it's cool yeah I love Kirsten Dunst but
that movie in particular just as this is
like a top level you know what I mean
yeah was she
really that's cool even think she's like
commercial starting commercial
sign commercial
you're not playing anywhere in age as
[__] if you could fly anywhere where
would you go
um
well I definitely Paris you know what I
mean you like Paris I love Paris yeah I
do too yeah Paris um
some are tropical maybe I don't know
Tokyo Japan maybe yeah
why don't I take a Tokyo baby
I didn't enjoy Tokyo as much as I
thought I would well I didn't enjoy
Tokyo as much as I thought I would why
not I bet you Japan is more interesting
than Tokyo
it was like a clean New York yeah Tokyo
is more stylized you know what I mean
it's more stylistic it's more like neoni
and there's like an um like an imperial
Electronica but you know I mean the rest
of Japan is more um
more Flora more I'm like dissipated but
very like Lush um
it's like a Utopia landscape you know
what I mean yeah the Japanese culture
comes through when you when you get
outside of Tokyo it's more um
mediated grounding you know what I mean
it's more traditional when you're inside
Tokyo it's more of a frenzy you know
what I mean it's very outrare
it again but the culture itself is so um
have you been huh have you been never
been I always want to go to Japan I
always want to go to Japan
in general you know what I mean so I
don't understand a little Tokyo here
it's more like a weird um
it's like a weird brick strip mall you
know I mean what kind of woman would you
be if you could be a woman what's your
favorite kind of woman I mean to be a
woman I mean like like
you want to be
how do you just you're you're Saudi you
want to be a Saudi woman or do you want
to be a french Paris a Parisian or do
you want to be
American or I know it's not to like box
women in but I think when I managed to
physically like compose my body into a
female form
it'll give me that added boost of like
um
I don't know if I'm gonna there's like a
boyishness you know what I mean to how I
am you know what I mean or like some
kind of like a like I should say like
kind of a I guess not being such a Sean
I think the male in me or the boy in me
is just like a brat you know what I mean
entitlement you know I mean
either just allow me to respect myself a
little more and behave more um
respectively what do you mean what kind
of woman you can't just box something
like that you know I mean like like
I love European women I love all kinds
of women but what is it about European
women education or is it pretension or
no their values seem to be a little bit
more in line with what mine are than how
you're typical like La girl
what's the difference I like girls I
guess they're more
fun or I know
but it depends on the girl too I hate to
stereotype oh women exactly are
different absolutely I think becoming a
woman would allow me to just
like all this Grime all this you know
you would just disappear
you know I should have good showered
bar soap would probably do that too
though
but
hi Joseph let me start here anyway
but what if a career kind of
a career would be great what a career
took off and all of a sudden you found
yourself really stimulated and
challenged and really into that career
then would you still need to be a woman
I definitely want to be a woman that's
not the um
that's not the uh
like I identify as female you know what
I mean it's just my genitalia it's just
in the way yeah see I'm still from the
Stone Age so I don't quite get that
exactly I don't want to say that you're
um
your knowledge of identity is different
it's just you're very composed as a man
you know what I mean and you would
understand what it is to feel incorrect
in your own Anatomy you know
yeah I've never I never not once have I
ever
imagined even being a female or changing
of your own composure if you ever had
any surgery at all even Botox no exactly
and this isn't composed in your own um
there's certain things about my face I
feel like would contort a certainly I
mean or my body you know
but you're an exceptionally I hate being
a man every part of my body like my
chest right you know what I'm here
you know I mean like my waist you know I
mean
the parts of it that are boyish are just
incorrect you know just kind of sagging
at her you know just kind of lankish
it's it's interesting how humans minds
work because like I appreciate women
probably as much as you do but I I like
being around someone who is what I think
is
you know particularly
thought men in or if I'm a native
feminine interesting beautiful whatever
you want to call it sexy whatever
exactly I think um but I don't I don't
ever think about a man I wish I could be
that
I definitely think the man and me are
the man in my body is um incorrect I
would say yeah no I mean you don't think
anything happened to you when you were
four years old six years old I'm so
sorry how many years no nothing no but
I'm wondering if something happened to
you that maybe oh no no never no no
this is just wait you were born this way
yeah just identifying as transgender
yeah yeah pretty much yeah no sorry I I
don't want to be here to question that
but
but I know I know about four trillion
men that would love to look like you do
I definitely don't want to be a man but
you know
when's the last time you took a shower
I can't remember honestly oh really well
yeah today's your day huh today's your
day I guess yeah
that's right your birthday's Friday yeah
what are we gonna do for your birthday
hmm yeah
I had to remember my birthday
you just we talked about the other day
all right yeah you're so [__] high
you don't remember
I know I only had a very bad short-term
memory
here's a room key
thank you
that's your room thanks don't [__] it up
I won't you [__] it up before
it'll be there for the reasons it's
there I don't know
somebody keep like clothes and I know
that and stuff
thanks Mikey sure yeah
if you behave you'll we'll keep it going
yeah
and then we'll see what goes what comes
of it from there yeah honestly I need a
job I need a career I need to Source
like stable income
and to reassemmate my life with the kind
of with Society you know what I mean
right but seeing who you are right now
at this moment you you're almost
hireable
I am almost horrible thank you Mark okay
I can behave I can assimilate it's just
being outside it gives me a Savage Edge
you know what I mean it makes me want to
misbehave or want to be a little more
obnoxious about it you know I mean like
being homeless you're allowed to um
I spent a lot of my time alone so I
suppose uh my behavior is a little more
aligned are you alone most of the time
yeah honestly yeah you don't have any
anyone you hang out with no one you go
to see in how in West Hollywood or
anything like that not really you know I
mean even when I go there I don't really
know anyone you know what I mean I'd
love to get to know people but honestly
at this point I'm just kind of a Hermit
you know what I mean yeah
would you would you describe yourself as
lonely
yes or just separated from society it's
kind of that's tragic because you're so
Charming it is it's buddhistic almost I
suppose it just um something that
happened I guess I know
I'd love to realign with Society it's
just at this point I'm kind of
everything that's keeping away from
society is kind of um
your personality is very erratic though
that makes it hard I can be irritating
about
um the who you are who you were the
other day just made me go I know no the
other day I was in a lot of pain
honestly when I'm in pain my feet were
killing you have no idea and it just
makes me like there's something about
pain in particular which I can never
understand you know what I mean your
feet are better right now oh yeah
definitely no I'm [__]
beautiful today
you know what I mean
you feel like the whole world's off to
get you for some reason you know
what do you need huh what do you need
you need clothes shoes clothes and food
shoes and stuff yeah
honest exchange and a career
I need to just reassemble it to society
honestly I think I'm done being a piece
of trash but it's been fun you know I
mean talk is cheap though huh talk is
cheap well I'm ready to do it
baby steps I need leeway you know what I
mean I need an entryway inside you know
anything at all
because the job is like a shitty stylist
for like a [__] whatever Studio or
whatever you know well maybe maybe if
you can show a little consistency
maybe somebody who watches your you know
the millions of people who watch your
videos might be like hey you know what
let's give Rebecca a chance
yeah I know it's just more like you
could intern for a week or so see how
that goes if you exactly nicely then
maybe they pay you and grows it goes
yeah
that's a possibility you're in the right
City for some of that definitely yeah um
as in Andrew went into industry or into
society you know what I mean well I mean
again social media is a way to do that
so sweet there's other presenting
oneself you know I mean are connecting
oneself to Matrix to people I was just
starting Instagram and express myself I
don't know I mean what you're doing here
with me right now and all the other
videos are like a springboard too
this is from where it fallacy honestly I
think they're just mostly um obnoxions
of um
you know no but like you've got so many
people that are interested in your story
there's been a handful of people you
Israel sharp whole bunch of them that
could have turned it into something the
only one that has is sharp and he's done
a great job of it
yeah and I'm ready too you know what I
mean I'm ready I'm done with this part
of my life Eric uh Portis wrote a book
you know which is great but uh but you
have so much potential so many people
are interested in fascinated by you I
think so just do something
anything
but don't just like become another
homeless exactly yeah no no I'm that's
why I'm trying to evade at this point
that's what's kind of like in my ways I
don't know how to get out of it you know
what I mean
so I was talking about like I need a
lawyer or some kind of you know I mean
yeah well let me let me help you maybe
we can do something yeah definitely yeah
thank you okay uh thanks Mark all right
I love you so much I love you Rebecca I
love you Mark I think you're amazing
thank you you'll be insulted if I called
you Ishmael right huh you'd be insulted
if I called you Ishmael definitely no
you finally gave us your name that was
so great yeah
my birth name your birth name you don't
go bye
is it your ish or anything like that
right no no not really I mean my friends
used to call me when I was younger I
guess or I know please call you what is
he yeah that's what I love about the
name um
he was the son that Abraham was supposed
to sacrifice right and then and it's not
doing I'm not religious
but I'll call you Rebecca for the time
being I'm Rebecca you are Rebecca sorry
excellent
until we do another one huh thank you
thank you